[Música]
liderazgo división o tolerancia hace más
de 2000 años un hombre dijo divide et
impera divide y vencerás este hombre
había dominado uno de los imperios más
grandes en la historia de la humanidad
usando como estandarte esta famosa frase
al final el conocido tirano julio césar
habría marcado una tendencia que
increíblemente sigue vigente al día de
hoy una tendencia que ha servido para
emborrachamiento de poder de unos
cuantos pero que difícilmente le ha
favorecido a aquellos que juraron
proteger
esta frase comenzó siendo aplicada hacia
la división de los enemigos
julio césar creía que si dividían las
alianzas de tus enemigos se volverían
más débiles y por ende triunfar en sus
conquistas y estaba en lo cierto pero
hoy en día las conquistas son diferentes
así como los tiranos pero la intención
es la misma llegar al poder
lo triste es que ahora no tratan de
dividir a unos cuantos para lograr sus
maquiavélicas intenciones porque ahora
quien llega al poder
no es quien gane en la batalla como la
antigua roma ahora llega al poder el que
más simpatizantes tiene al líder es el
que escoge y la cantidad de líderes a lo
largo de la historia moderna en todo el
mundo que ha llegado a través de la
división de sus propios pueblos es
altísimo piénsalo por un momento
desde el inicio de los 1900
cuántos discursos de odio clasismo
racismo xenofobia conspiranoicos entre
muchos otros años mismos que llevaron a
indeseables para sillas más poderosas
que existen
desde sus inicios se plantean enemigos
estás conmigo o eres malo si piensas
como yo eres patriota usan teorías que
inculpan a ciertos sectores de todos los
males que existen en el país encabezar
una cruzada para proteger al bando que
ellos escojan echándole la culpa al otro
pero no importa cual sea el mal que
curen combatir siempre tratarán de
proteger a la minoría más grande y
ustedes me dirán bueno si llega a luchar
por una causa justa cuál es el problema
el problema radica cuando no solo hay
una división entre las ideas de la misma
población el problema es cuando se
convierte en polarización social
la polarización social es el fenómeno
que segrega una sociedad y surge a
partir de movimientos sociales que
principalmente encabeza los líderes de
opinión caudillos gobernantes políticos
propios en la lucha de clases
es una división total entre los ideales
intereses y objetivos de un pueblo
que en méxico haya tenido al hombre más
rico del mundo y que haya 50 millones de
pobres
que los jóvenes se quejen de un programa
que le da becas a ninis
y se gaste lo mismo en una noche de
antro
tiene un lado de la avenida todos se
transportan en coches privados y el otro
se transporten en camión o transporte
público
eso es polarización social y va mucho
más allá de la división económica es una
división radical de ideas pensamientos
encaminados hacia un bien común
y es que un pueblo polarizado lejos de
no compartir ideas no comparte valores
no se encamina hacia las mismas causas
no se pone de acuerdo en una agenda
progresista para el país se vuelve un
obstáculo para resolver uno de los retos
globales más urgentes como la reducción
de la pobreza el cambio climático la
desigualdad del desarrollo y la lista
sigue
muchos de estos objetivos han sido
comprometidos ante organizaciones
mundiales como los solenses los
objetivos de desarrollo sustentable que
voy a tocar un tema de esos
muchas veces confundimos la polarización
con la discrepancia de creencias y es
algo que no va por ahí
podemos pensar que a lo mejor no es un
problema tan grande porque al final de
cuentas la diversidad de ideas enriquece
la cultura del país y sí
el problema yace cuando las ideas son
tan contrastantes y aquellos que las
tienen se vuelven intolerantes a la idea
contraria y nos llegan un acuerdo
benéfico para ninguno de los dos
y esto en específico nos pasa a todos y
te voy a poner un ejemplo súper sencillo
quien no se ha quedado sin ver nada en
netflix porque no se decidían qué
película ver y esa es una decisión
totalmente mundana pequeña imagínense a
ahora las decisiones que definen el
rumbo de un país
para que sean una idea hace un par de
meses tuve la oportunidad de
parece una invitación para una mesa de
trabajo con el fin de desarrollar una
estrategia para reducir la tasa de
embarazos adolescentes
esto en específico en la ciudad donde
vivo y para no hacerles el cuento largo
el grupo se dividió en dos unos querían
hablando conceptivos a los jóvenes y los
otros decían que esto sería
contraproducente porque incitaría a los
jóvenes a tener relaciones
las ideas totalmente contrastantes
y no me entrar en qué posición era la
correcta pero el punto es que después de
horas de discusión debate pelea
y no se llegó a ningún acuerdo ni en
cómo se debería llamar el programa y el
resultado esperado de bajar la tasa por
supuesto que no se cumplió
un problema que podría pensarse sencillo
no tuvo solución mientras me hizo
reflexionar sobre qué pasará a la gran
escala que pasará a la hora de decidirse
las políticas públicas que definen el
rumbo
del país
me di cuenta que hoy en día la agenda
legislativa
en los temas relevantes en los temas de
debate
como la legalización de la marihuana o
del aborto el matrimonio igualitario de
la eutanasia entre muchos otros
en nuestro país llevan años debatiéndose
sin llegar a ningún resultado que
beneficie a alguno de los lados y la
opinión pública fluctúa según las
tendencias del momento
en tanto tiempo debate lo único que se
ha logrado es que el problema crezca y
ninguno de los bandos que pelean por
estas causas se ha visto beneficiado
insisto
para hacernos una idea de lo que les
comentaba del oso de heces la agenda
2030 la agenda más importante a nivel
internacional de los 17 objetivos de
desarrollos estables que se
establecieron méxico llevó un avance del
75 por ciento en sólo 3
solo 3
o sea ya pasaron dos tercios del tiempo
para cumplir esta agenda de los otros
catorce no sea un avance ni de tres
cuartos veinte años después de que se
hicieran estos compromisos en la onu
tampoco quiero decir que todo esto sea
culpa de la polarización social pero no
tengo ninguna duda
que si logramos ponernos un poquito más
de acuerdo encontraríamos soluciones
mucho mucho más rápido
ahora imagínense que aquellos a los que
elegimos para resolver estos problemas
en consenso no solo no tratan de buscar
el beneficio en común acuerdo' generando
comunidad la comunidad
sino que basan su liderazgo en dividir
en seguir dividiendo la opinión pública
al punto de polarizar y generar odio
entre ideas entre la diferencia de
opiniones con el fin de generar
simpatizantes y conservar su poder
ojos simpatizantes de la minoría más
grande
a dónde nos va a llevar esto o mejor a
dónde nos ha llevado
resumió en una palabra
estancamiento
fragmentos de ideas
de proyectos en estar de desarrollo
y la lista sigue y sigue
lo hayas pensado alguna vez
bueno eso es culpa de los gobernantes y
no es nuestra culpa porque el pueblo es
el que elige dividirse el pueblo es el
que acepta creerle al caudillo que
señala al vecino como malo porque piensa
diferente el pueblo es quien cree en los
enemigos inventados el pueblo es el que
basa su realidad en los tonos blanco y
negro contrastantes
tonos que los poderosos no señalan
aunque algunos líderes con la finalidad
de dividirnos señalan pero en la vida
existen muchísimos tonos de grises
muchísimas formas de ver las cosas
sé que muchos piensan que no hay remedio
para este gran problema
porque somos esclavos de los medios que
somos seguido de la educación y lo que
ustedes quieran
pero si lo hay
sé que estaba haciendo muchas preguntas
en los últimos momentos pero puedes
imaginar cuál es
en realidad es mucho más sencillo
la salida de la polarización social
el racismo el clasismo
de la homofobia xenofobia y cualquier
mal que pueda abanderar un líder que
busque dividir
se llama tolerancia social
la tolerancia implica aceptar
las creencias de uno
no tienen que imponerse son las del
resto
vivimos en un mundo donde
desgraciadamente
reina su enemigo la intolerancia de la
mano de su mejor aliado
tolerar significa ser conscientes de que
alguien piensa distinto a nosotros y lo
aceptamos
pero no caemos en la soberbia de que el
que somos los únicos dueños de la razón
seamos tolerantes y aceptemos los unos
con otros con nuestros ideales y
creencias porque dejarte un pequeño
grupo de personas afecta el
comportamiento racional de millones
unámonos nosotros como mexicanos como
jóvenes como universitarios como seres
humanos caray
pongámonos en el lugar del otro
pongámonos en sus zapatos y entendamos
por qué piensa así
saquémonos el chip de que nuestro
pensamiento es el único correcto
silvio rodríguez decía una frase que
dice tolerancia tolerancia
para abrirte en el mantel pocos platos
se las sirven muchas bocas a comer
qué frase
cuánta verdad y es que es tan cierta
porque todos somos tolerantes hasta que
alguien piense diferente y ahí
justo ahí
es donde todo el problema nos lleva a
promotores
e impulsores de la polarización social
si dejáramos que este valor imperan en
nuestras comunidades no habrá peleas
entre prohibidas y pro abortos entre
religiosos y ateos entre los nuevos y
los de siempre entre carlos y crisis
en la vista así
por el contrario se solucionarían mucho
más rápido las diferencias encaminado a
una ideología de ganar ganar y no de
ganar y que el otro pierda porque piensa
diferente y por eso está equivocado
mejor aún
si se generará conciencia
quizás
a lo mejor en un futuro
la tendencia no sea que la sociedad
arroje líderes
que se basen en la división de la
minoría más grande
quizás la tendencia
o sea encontrar liderazgos
de tolerancia
que una en una verdadera mayoría